hajhadi sells cold water on al-rashid
street
a busy neighborhood in the iraqi capital
like many here he says he was hopeful
for a new government to improve services
in his area
we've had enough what shall i say if
politicians can't form a government they
should quit this situation can't
continue we have wasted decades waiting
for change
a parliament on hold
this is what iraq's council of
representatives looks like seven months
since it was elected
with no common ground between its rival
blocks to pick a new president and
cabinet
divisions created by different agendas
and affiliations along political
interests
it's an interesting conflict over who
controls the sheer decision mukta
al-sadr wants not to share a government
with the iranian-backed parties but
those parties want the consensus
government to guarantee their share of
power
however people are fed up with old faces
that's also part of the reason al-sadr
is encouraged to reject the
iranian-backed parties who have been in
power for several years
the bloc led by influential cleric
has the majority of seeds
it is backed by a sunni coalition led by
parliament speaker muhammad al-busi
as well as the kurdistan democratic
party
whereas the shia coalition backed by
iran
is allied with the patriotic union of
kurdistan party
and a number of independent members
since 2005 there has been a political
norm to choose a kurdish president
shia prime minister and a sunni speaker
of parliament
this impasse has been highlighted
by the un special representative to iraq
janine placeheart
in her latest briefing at the u.n she
urged the political elite to end the
deadlock
and move on with forming a government to
tackle a long list of priorities
a change of government was one of the
top demands of the 2019 mass protests
against corruption and mismanagement
the current impasse means incumbent
president perham saleh and prime
minister mustafa al-qasim's caretaker
government
will likely remain in office until a
consensus is reached
but this means changes related to
improving people's lives also remain on
hold
foreign